[Music]
on this friday night
masks made in canada for canadians
the critical deal to produce coveted ppe
canada was left at the mercy of other
countries
how much will be made and when covet
crowd control
bc's hefty fines for offenders these
actions
could cost people their lives and flight
fears
what raises and reduces the spread of
the virus inside planes
plus pandemic problem solving
complicated is an understatement
a boarding school navigates border rules
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin tonight with a major deal to
help give canada its own supply of
critical ppe
the federal and ontario governments have
secured an agreement with manufacturing
giant 3m
to produce n95 masks at a facility in
brockville ontario
ottawa and ontario will each receive 25
million masks per year
over 5 years for healthcare and other
essential workers
ontario premier doug ford and prime
minister justin trudeau were both
on hand for the announcement but as our
chief political correspondent david
aiken is here to tell us
trudeau couldn't escape more questions
about his decision to shut down
parliament
david well robin 3m is going to get a
combined 47 million dollars from the
governments of canada
and ontario 3m will use that money to
expand this
plant buy some new equipment and ramp up
manufacture of
n95 masks the n95 mask
is a crucial piece of personal
protective equipment for front-line
healthcare workers and caregivers
but when the pandemic first hit earlier
this year canada and the provinces were
forced to scramble to find enough of
them
we were left in a terrible terrible
situation and i can tell you
worrying about where we would get the
next ppe shipment
that's what kept me up at night at one
point ontario
was down to less than a week's supply
and u.s president donald trump was
threatening to
ban exports from 3m's plant in minnesota
to customers in canada ever since the
two levels of government have been
working to secure
a domestic supply of ppe like the n95
mask
today i know that ontario will never
have to depend on another country for
the n95 mass
we need to protect our nurses and
doctors are front line heroes
but in a week that saw the prime
minister appoint a new finance minister
after the previous one
resigned then suspend parliament then
roll out a 37 billion dollar overhaul of
canada's social safety net
well the questions he took here were
about his political judgment
the throne speech we put forward eight
months ago
is not aligned with the reality people
are facing today there was no mention of
covet 19.
that's why prorogation is a logical and
reasonable step
but block cable claw leader e francois
blanchett tweeted this
about trudeau's parliamentary tactics
saying i warned the prime minister
against the temptation to hold workers
and businesses
hostage to force the adoption of the
speech from the throne
trudeau shrugged off the criticism if
the other parties disagree with
extending the serb
or getting people on ei they need to say
that
now as for that 3m deal it involves
50 million masks a year coming out of
this plant
half will go to ontario half will go to
the federal government to be distributed
around the country
production begins in january robin
david aiken in brockville ontario thanks
david
there is a grim reminder tonight that
it's not just the elderly at risk in
this pandemic
quebec has reported its youngest victim
of covert 19.
a friend has identified him as 19 year
old don benitengu
this is sapu four years ago in a city of
montreal video
speaking about his birthplace the
democratic republic of congo
according to an online fundraiser set up
to help cover funeral costs
he died of complications from the virus
on august 16th
his father told other media he had no
underlying health conditions
deaths from coven 19 are extremely rare
in young people but there's a growing
number of younger canadians
contracting the virus according to the
public health agency of canada since
early july canadians under the age of 39
have accounted for the highest
proportion of new cases
in the last week they accounted for 63
percent
of all new cases here's a look at the
situation across the country today
there are 131 new infections in ontario
and 93
in quebec in western canada infections
are also rising
there are 144 new cases in alberta
and 90 in bc new enforcement measures
are coming into effect in bc to try to
get the new spike in
infections under control according to
the province police can now fine people
up to two thousand dollars
for hosting large gatherings like this
recent beach party
which violates public health orders
people who promote large events or who
are ordered to leave large events
and refuse can be fined up to two
hundred dollars
there is a small minority of selfish
individuals across the province who are
disregarding the public health measures
in place large house parties
unsanctioned events on our streets on
our beaches
enough is enough anyone who hosts an
event and fails to gather guests contact
information
can also be fined under the new measures
if you've been on a plane recently it's
worth checking government lists warning
of possible covenanting exposures
in the last few weeks dozens of flights
both domestic and
international have been flagged for
potential exposures
experts say the risk of catching the
virus in flight is low
but as heather york's west explains
published research
is raising serious questions during what
is usually a busy travel season
the threat of covet 19 has made canada's
airports eerily quiet
heather jeremiah is heading to edmonton
to visit family
keeping masks on her three kids has been
tough but she says
otherwise flying has felt safe none of
us are high risk none of us have
underlying conditions
and you know i feel like i feel pretty
okay in an interview with cbc last month
canada's transport minister said there
is no evidence there is not a case yet
of somebody actually picking up the
virus on board the aircraft
but since the pandemic began scientists
have identified
several possible cases of in-flight
transmission
one happened on a late january flight
between singapore and china
the person had been sitting near four
infected passengers for an
hour and didn't use his mask properly a
second single case was traced back to a
flight between the central african
republic
and paris in late february while two
others were believed to have been
acquired aboard an early march flight
between tel aviv and frankfurt
all cases occurred before masks were
mandatory on planes
if i needed to fly okay if i had a an
ill
close relative somewhere across the
country
then i would i would probably not
hesitate dr allison mcgear says the risk
of transmission during air travel
increases if passengers are coming from
endemic areas
but on board air filtration systems and
masks reduce the risk
it's why the airline industry is pushing
ottawa to consider loosening its
position
on non-essential travel we are operating
at about 15 percent
of the traditional year-over-year
capacity for this time of year
we cannot sustain this for an indefinite
period of time
still if travelers are carrying on covid
no amount of on-board precautions will
eliminate the risk of transmission
during the flight and after those
passengers land
heather urex west global news calgary
herd immunity when kova 19 can no longer
spread effectively in the population
has been both touted and dismissed as a
solution to the pandemic
but most experts believe a safe and
widely distributed vaccine will be
necessary
before we can put covet in the rear view
mirror as eric sorensen reports
epidemiologists are keeping an eye on
populations from new york to spain to
india
for signs that herd immunity is
achievable sooner
rather than later could this the
overcrowded slums of mumbai
be a front line in defeating the novel
coronavirus
testing suggests more than half the
people living here have been infected
and health officials believe the region
may be inching towards the prime
objective in the pandemic
herd immunity indian experts and others
suggest
an immunity threshold at 50 percent of
the population or even lower
could be enough to curb the spread of
the virus
fresh cases are coming but people are no
longer afraid says this mumbai
shopkeeper
see i'm not wearing a mask the only way
out of this is herd immunity either
artificial or natural
artificial where a vaccine provides
immunity natural where people get the
virus then become
immune raywatt dianandin is skeptical
that herd immunity is close at hand
globally this isn't one epidemic it's
multiple epidemics with different
profiles and different geographies
around the world
herd immunity in simple terms works like
this a percentage of the population gets
infected with a virus
and then that group becomes immune if
it's large enough
it then offers protection to those who
are not immune and are still vulnerable
so if i come along with a virus my
contacts with those who are immune
doesn't allow the virus to spread the
question is what percentage immunity is
required
to hold the virus in check the
epidemiological consensus is around 70
percent of the population must be immune
to achieve
herd immunity and we're not close to
that yet we need to focus
on what we can actually do now to
suppress transmission and not live in
hope
of herd immunity been our salvation
there is still more to learn on immunity
says deonandin
some people believe that kids couldn't
get it and couldn't transmit it now we
know for sure they can and they do
the question is how much do they do so
it's an important question because in
canada children are just about to go
back to school by the millions
and it's not even clear say experts how
long immunity lasts
when somebody is infected with this
virus we expect that they develop an
immune response
what we are learning right now is how
strong that response is
and for how long that response will last
we do not have a complete picture of
this yet
immunity will rise around the world as
more covet 19 patients recover
but herd immunity may not come before
there's a vaccine
eric sorensen global news toronto
the conservative party is hurting in
last minute votes as the party's
leadership race
inches closer to the finish line today
is the last day for ballots to be
submitted
leslie lewis peter mckay aaron o'toole
and derek sloane are all in the running
for the top job
to replace andrew scheer the party says
just over 269
thousand people are eligible to vote in
the conservative leadership
more than a hundred and fifty thousand
votes have already been cast
making it the highest turnout for the
election of a federal party leader
in canadian history because of the
pandemic all voting is being done
by mail-in ballots a winner will be
announced on sunday night
and global news will have live
continuous coverage of how the
conservative leadership vote goes down
on sunday starting at 6 eastern 3
pacific
you can watch it live on our website
globalnews.ca
the global news youtube channel or on
the global tv app
we'll also have all the results and
analysis right here
on global national to the united states
for the future of the u.s postal service
and its role in november's presidential
election
are in the spotlight some lawmakers have
accused the postmaster of voter
suppression
after he planned to decommission
hundreds of mail sorting machines
and sent out letters to almost every
state saying thousands of mail-in votes
may not be counted in time for the
election today
he told a different story jennifer
johnson reports
as we head into the election season
postmaster general lewis dejoy defended
the removal of mail collection boxes
after he took over the u.s postal
service in june
and said plans to remove hundreds of
mail sorting machines will be put on
hold
so millions of mail-in ballots in
november's election can be counted
i want to assure this committee and the
american public
that the postal service is fully capable
and committed to delivering the nation's
election mail
securely and on time but postal workers
say high volume sorting machines that
process 35 000 pieces of mail an hour
and are in good condition have already
been taken out of service and dismantled
under dejoy's watch from michigan to
oregon to iowa
has definitely changed how our customers
are receiving the mail we're seeing a
significant
delay in the mail millions more
americans are expected to vote by mail
in this election due to the covet 19
pandemic
democrats feared to join a major trump
re-election donor
might have been influenced to engage in
voter suppression you will give us your
word today
under oath that you have not taken any
action whatsoever in your capacity
as postmaster general for any political
reason what i
instructed the organization the whole
team around us and out in the field
whatever efforts we will have double
them but some democrats say dejoy should
resign
i believe he should step down i think
he's lost the confidence of the vast
majority of americans and postal workers
the postal service had already informed
46 states and the district of columbia
many ballots likely wouldn't be counted
on time president trump has repeatedly
said without any evidence
millions of fraudulent ballots will be
cast by mail
51 million votes it's being sent
and nobody knows who's getting them the
president cast his vote by mail for
tuesday's primary in florida
de joy says he often votes by mail too
jennifer johnson global news washington
democrats in the u.s have made their
choice official joe biden will be the
party's presidential candidate
biden spoke during last night's finale
of the democratic national convention
but a 13-year-old boy's brave two-minute
speech in front of millions
may have stolen the show without joe
biden
i wouldn't be talking to you today about
a few
months ago i met him in new hampshire he
told me that we were members of the same
club
we
stutter it was really amazing to hear
that someone like me
became advice
president
braden harrington says biden helped him
become a more confident speaker by
sharing his own struggles the former
vice president has spoken frequently
about how
overcoming a severe childhood stutter
was one of the hardest things he's done
in life a new twist in russia coming up
what doctors are now
saying about the opposition leader in
intensive care
the kremlin is keeping a close eye on
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
who is fighting for his life
the fierce critic of president vladimir
putin is in a coma
after a suspected poisoning in a major
turn of events russian doctors are now
allowing navalny to be flown to a german
medical clinic for treatment
and as crystal comancing reports they've
also changed their minds on
what may have caused his illness
distraught and angry alexei navalny's
wife accuses russian officials
of blocking her from speaking with
german physicians brought in to take
over her husband's care
on thursday doctors were looking at the
possibility that the 44 year old
had been poisoned now the chief doctor
at the hospital in amsgrusha is
downplaying that
saying no poison was found in his body
doctors there also initially denied a
request from navalny's wife to transfer
him to germany
saying it was too big of a risk to his
life
suddenly like some something was
switched off like medicine
mode of cover-up operation mode on
and the doctors refuse to cooperate
anymore
a charity group that organizes donations
for humanitarian projects was asked to
arrange a medical air transfer
the condition of the russian dissident
is being closely monitored by the
international community
we expect a swift independent
transparent investigation
and if confirmed those responsible must
be held
[Music]
has been a persistent thorn in the side
of russian president vladimir putin
and the kremlin has a long history of
being accused
of poisoning its enemies crystal
gomencing global news
london still ahead deadly fires and
smoky skies smother the golden state
watching global national
dozens of fires are burning in the san
francisco bay area and central
california
five people have been killed and at
least 175 buildings including homes have
been destroyed
tens of thousands more are at risk much
of the state is blanketed in a thick
layer of smoke
in recent days northern california has
registered the worst air quality
in the world this map from the national
oceanic and atmospheric administration
shows smoke from the wildfires reaching
across much of the country stretching
into canada
and mexico the golden state killer may
have avoided the death penalty under a
plea deal but
he will still die in prison joseph
deangelo
a former california police officer was
sentenced to multiple life terms today
deangelo pleaded guilty to 13 murders
and 13 rape related charges
committed between 1975 and 1986.
he also publicly admitted to dozens of
other sexual assaults
he eluded capture for four decades
before being identified
through dna quarantining 101
the advanced degree of safety at one
quebec boarding school
that's next
with cova 19 this is far from a regular
school year
and for boarding schools there are some
extra complications
take stansted college it's about 130
kilometers southeast of montreal
tucked in just a few hundred meters from
the u.s border
as mike armstrong explains the fact that
the border is closed
is making it difficult especially when
you consider half the students are from
outside the country it's been used for
one year this is stansted college's
newest
dorm well as of next week it'll also be
a quarantine facility
the signs are ready to go up classes at
the college don't start for another
couple of weeks but
international students are being asked
to come early and
spend two weeks mostly in their room
we've told them to bring whatever they
need to keep themselves entertained for
14 days
so books and videos and computers and
they'll have their phones of course
stansted college is the kind of place
most of us see in movies
it's a private high school grade 7
through 12 with a price tag
per year that can be close to 70 000
well like most schools in canada it shut
down last spring over covet 19.
it was exactly at spring break joanne
carruthers is the director of admissions
she says moving to online classes was a
challenge but moving
everyone back for this semester is even
tougher
i would say complicated is an
understatement normally these
single tables would be double tables the
college usually has about 245 students
and about half of that comes from
outside canada well this year some can't
enrollment will be down we had four
students from germany for example
who had to make a decision by the end of
july based on requirements from germany
so they said because we there's
uncertainty still about getting to
canada
we're not coming international students
arrive monday and tuesday and that's
complicated too
they have to be shuttled from the
airport in montreal directly to the
school for the mandatory 14-day
quarantine
our vans are going to be specially set
up so that there's going to be plastic
dividers between the driver and the
students
if i have a class here the planning for
how everything will work is still
underway
as soon as they solve one problem two
new ones pop up
but one thing's clear this school year
is going to be different for example
temperature checks before you enter the
dining hall
covid 19 is complicating the return to
classes right across canada
this is our health center but while most
schools worry about school hours
a boarding school has to worry about
every hour day
and night mike armstrong global news
stanstead quebec
and that is global national for this
friday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is new brunswick
pedicodiac river
also known as the chocolate river you
can see why
thank you for watching jeff semple will
be here over the weekend and i'll see
you again on monday
have a great weekend